[Musique]
on n'a pas les visuels alors fabien on
va passer maintenant à une nouvelle
séquence et terrassera je vais te sortir
tous les doutes sur toi des infos
insolites des photos bref des dossiers
la première a sera pour toi fabien c'est
un classique c'est ta première télé tu
t'en souviens la première télé ou pas la
chaleur du son c'est en 2005 voilà
c'était chez tirade ils sont a pas
beaucoup changé bref c'est le même
délire ta patrie
franchement de 25 à 13 ans 13 mx-5
tacchella je la chante
et ben voilà bah c'était batave est donc
moins 13 mois tu fais le calcul que tu
m'as fait dans la semaine à regarder
vous pas d'être à dire mon coeur qu'elle
s'en bat les couilles si mes couilles
avait mal au coeur et que ça crée des
embrouilles
mais mes coups et entendu et 10 à ma
tête qu'elle a pas de coeur et comment
caire n'a pas de coût et matete pas près
d'avoir peur moi mes cuisses en tête en
l'air et en tant qu en artichaut et
quand mon coeur perd la tête mais
couverts est bien au chaud
et si ma tête part en couilles pour mon
coeur c'est la défaite je devais cette
histoire parker elle manifeste est bon
les femmes je les crains autant que je
suis fou d'elle vous comprenez
maintenant pourquoi chez moi c'est un
sacré bordel j'ai pas trouvé la solution
ça fait un moment que je fouille
je resterai son contrôle de ma tête mon
coeur et mes couilles
la télé fabien où sa tombe et non
franchement ça va ce rapprochement
tarder ce que tu es sympathique tu te
marque
bah ouais non mais c'est quand même des
moments plutôt ça parlera pas se
plaindre on parle de ses albums on parle
de ce qu'on fait il ya plein d'artistes
qui aimeraient pouvoir tu vas faire de
la promo donc non j'aime bien je meurs
tu aimes bien oui c'est vrai qu'en plus
nous comptons reçoit caen corps malade
on est content allegri toronto vont te
kiffe la calme toi toi même si
aujourd'hui le grill m elle va bien tu
aimes bostjan conti vincent oui bah oui
oui même dans le film mais je sais c'est
justement le film qui est nommé aux
césar
le mans il a énuméré quatre fois que
j'ai vu césar excellent film vraiment et
bravo à jean rachid ecoutez-la évoqué
pour passer à ta début de saison on va
reparler d'ailleurs de francky vincent
est ce que tu te rappelles d'un moment
où tu as déjà chanté ses chansons à
francky vincent tu étais pas loin de moi
je pendrai c'était sur europe 1 c'était
une bonne race après toi et un bon
moment pour nous regarde nous est
délicieux et peut-être vicieux je
deviens tout puissant dans ce lit
excitant
alice ça glisse au pays des merveilles
bravo franck il se sentait groseille
éraillée ça glisse au pays des
merveilles mourao francky c'est du savon
de marseille et ça marche
[Applaudissements]
ces quatre cinq fois faux pas des
archives de moi y'a toujours véloce ou
mardi l'émouvante avec elle à detroit
mais tout le temps tu sais tu vas passer
d'un régime que moi dans mon genre
direct suis tout le temps même si rennes
bat c ça changera jamais ça on est on
est quand même grave et la bible à
raucoules rien merci way it à temps
j'étais à la millénaire quoi la tient
alors ils édition milanais savaient avec
les insectes et je kiffais parce que
j'étais vraiment je l avais valver
d'europe erc ouais ouais
la nuit de la 1000e émission un truc
avec moi avec les affaires et j'ai eu
très peur et c'est l'affectif et j'ai le
policier merci monsieur je vous comprend
beaucoup mieux jean michel ménard garder
une petite photo de toi enfin je t'ai
dit que j'avais khedira très regardée
comme ici où là je voudrais pas que tu
as quel âge là dessus j'ai pas eu huit
ans nikam quoi il n'a pas bougé
j'avais malentendu sur la tête menacent
nos pays kwassa minikeums et oubli soit
une bonne c'était une haute corse a
cessé le maire en plus en est là c'est
un peu comme tout le monde
ces raretés d'école à 8 ans ils ont une
moustache 500 ils sont en berne
mais tu es en bas mais elle sort un truc
messas grand lit ça pousse un brigand
c'est maintenant tu es petit tu
ressembles à toi même mais on peut tuer
les gars font tuer il faut passer la
main tutu avait emporté sept ans jean le
cam ça mais c'est faux
c'est vrai qu'à des gars il fait et ce
en quoi ils s il sur fond de mettre cap
ils font de même
quand tu étais j'étais déjà mais non
ouais mais elle avait du succès à
l'époque avec les tubes a énormément
cela ça rigole je suis sûr parce que toi
tu es le mec on veut pécho à l'atteindre
avec c'est peut-être là sur toi huit ans
pour moi j'ai déjà 8 ans ou des peurs et
j'avais déjà une barre et tous à 8 ans a
tellement habitants moi j'avais déjà
bobards est touché à une station où nous
fêtons à wayne était mignon que moi
s'amuse rev'it mois frères mois 13 ans
mon frère a jamais une miss l'acheter
les brigades du tigre à l'arrêt
moustache que le gars derrière alors
cette photo est allé dans ton petit
pocahontas tu es ce que tu avais fait un
clip qui était magnifique aussi qu'on
avait passé ici dans cette émission
fabien on va pas se mentir il ya
énormément de personnes d'humoristes qui
ont tenté de l'imiter mais il ya fatal
bazooka notamment qu'il a fait en fait
c'est vincent desagnat qui s'était mis
dans ta peau avec un slam tout en poésie
regarde ça
[Musique]
j'aiderai je t'aime slan quand cette
maladie qui l'hiver l'anus mérite un
virus venu du froid qu'on appelle gastro
entérite
la prochaine fois je mettrai ma cagoule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on parle slam on dirait celui-ci
s'est tout de suite très bien quand on
parodie quand on ne dit rien pas
franchement j'ai déjà où j'ai beaucoup
d'autodérision a pas de souci et puis
après tu vois quand tu as ta marionnette
aux guignols et où c'est forcément c'est
plus gratifiant du fonds d'aidé parodie
dans l'eure dans leurs clips
c'est la mairie qui font pas ça peut
être un peu moins
[Rires]